hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of mulling the Masters I
believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow a business is to
model the strategies of people who've
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're going to look at how a young
man who loved the theater started doing
puppet shows on a local TV station and
turned it into one of the most beloved
puppet franchises in the world this is
the story of Muppets found there Jim
Henson and the top three lessons you can
learn from his success Jim Henson was
the son of a stay-at-home mom and a
father that was working for the
Department of Agriculture his mother
spent hours entertaining him and his
siblings for making up stories and
allowing them to use their imagination
his childhood was a happy one as he
spent countless hours exploring the
shorelines of Deer Creek one of his most
significant relationships early on was
with a young friend Kermit who would
later inspire one of his most celebrated
Muppets Henson developed a close
relationship with his maternal
grandmother who was an artist herself
and occupied her time painting quilting
and doing needlework she was the main
motivating force behind Henson's efforts
constantly cheering on his artistic
talents and encouraging him to put his
creative imagination to use as a
freshman at the University of Maryland
he was given the chance to perform
puppets on a twice daily 5-minute show
on wrc-tv he created salmon friends with
fellow student Jane Nebel whom he later
married in 1959 the show ran for six
years while Henson continued to pursue
his degree in arts and theater design
salmon friends was a testing ground for
numerous Muppet characters that would
later become instantaneously
recognizable including Henson's
signature character Kermit the Frog it
also allowed him to experiment with new
techniques that will allow for the
puppets to appear more lifelike such as
using special framing to allow the
puppeteer to work off-camera Henson was
no exception in the world of
entrepreneurship he too experienced the
disappointment of failure and faced the
challenge of staying motivated but he
knew that he had Talent and through the
highs and lows of his career Henson all
the while remained unwilling to give up
on his goals drawing strengthened
from a higher power Henson doggedly
continued to chase of dreams the hard
work and faith paid off because the
Muppets have become some of the most
beloved characters on television today
entertaining millions of children from
around the world by tapping into his
creativity and by experimenting with new
ideas Jim Henson was able to turn a
small-time puppet show on TV into an
internationally recognized brand to help
you tap into your creativity
here are three auction items you can
learn from Jim Henson option number one
remain faithful to yourself as long as
you believe in yourself you have hope
it's possible you can get to where you
want to go your business will likely
change multiple times from when you
started it no matter how great an idea
you have it's gonna change as you start
talking to customers if you believe that
what you're doing is right and is
helping people keep going don't give up
do something every day to move your
business forward and remain faithful to
yourself or you'll regret it for the
rest of your life
despite being rebuffed on countless
occasions and underestimated as a
provider of simple and fluffy children's
entertainment Henson was resolute in his
capacity to blaze his own path and make
his mark in the industry as a serious
artist he knew he had strengths bolston
puppetry and television production and
sought to find a unique way to combine
the two his confidence allowed him to be
willing to take chances and try new
routes puppeteer Ian was not a popular
profession and there were few role
models to whom Henson could look for for
inspiration but Henson knew where his
talents lay and he did not anticipate
the scope of his own success he always
knew he can make a positive contribution
and in a different way than most by
having faith in himself Henson was able
to reinvent the world of puppetry and
enrich imaginations around the world
according to Henson the show's not dead
as long as I believe in it I think if
you study if you learn too much of what
others have done you may tend to take
the same directions everyone else it's
just a matter of figuring out how to
receive the ideas or information that
are waiting to be heard I find that it
really helped me to start the day with a
good frame of reference
as part of my prayers I think whoever's
helping me I'm sure that somebody or
something is action item number to
remain positive about your goals as
entrepreneurs we want things to happen
immediately unfortunately the world
often makes us wait hold on to your
goals and know that they are possible as
long as you have hope you think of ways
to make things work out seconds that
motivate you and that provide value to
others and don't let them go until you
reach them when you believe in them
others around you will as well an
eternal optimist Henson took uniquely
spiritual approach to his work he
believed that he was on the earth to
achieve something that would contribute
back to others as long as he tried to
create a positive message through his
work the results would be positive in
return it was this optimism that allowed
Henson to succeed even in the face of
rejection and doubt
despite the often negative response and
Henson got to his ideas he looked upon
everything as a learning experience and
a growth opportunity Henson recognized
that there would always be a certain
amount of negativity and suffering not
only in his own life but also throughout
the world however he saw little point in
wasting his energies focusing on that
instead he directed his energies towards
more constructive efforts
according to Henson I believe in taking
a positive attitude toward the world
toward people toward my work I believe
that we form our own lives that we
create our own reality and that
everything works out for the best I
think this is why we're here to work our
way through all this and hopefully come
out a bit wiser I'm better for having
gone through it all I know I drive some
people crazy with what seems to be
ridiculous optimism but it has always
worked out for me action item number
three take the road less traveled you've
got to do something different to stand
out doing the same thing as everyone
else is not a recipe for success
find out what's unique about you as an
individual and your business leverage
your uniqueness and show people how
you're different
don't try to market to everyone find
your niche provide overwhelming value
and then expand your customer base
hence it not only revolutionized
children's television around the world
but with this pioneering technology you
who brought puppetry to a higher level
his success came from being able to
devise a new way to approach an ancient
form Henson set what would become the
new standard in the industry with his
imaginative ability to think outside the
box
it was Henson's innovative and
pioneering spirit that served as major
drivers of his success he refused to
settle for the status quo and insisted
on creating something new fresh and fun
it was a risk but one that eventually
paid off The Muppets have leapt off the
television screens and become part of
families around the world according to
Henson you know that my feeling about
puppetry relates to stylization
simplicity boiling down to it's a
wonderful form and I really love it
nobody creates a fad it just happens
people love going along with the idea of
a beautiful pig it's like a conspiracy
life's like a movie write your own
ending keep believing keep pretending
simple is good
so remember remain faithful to yourself
remain positive about your goals and
take the road less traveled to finish up
this video I wanted to share one of my
favorite true stories about Jim Henson
and some of his best quotes Kermit was
not always the best-known character Jim
Henson created in fact the most popular
character originally was Rolf the doc
Henson created this Muppet for Purina
Dog Chow and it became an instant hit in
1962 long before Kermit was known to
most people not only was Rowlf the dog
more popular the character was a regular
on the Jimmy Dean show throughout 1965 a
full decade before the Muppet Show ever
aired for the first time on PBS
thank you for joining me for another
edition modeling masters if you liked
the video and you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below I'd
also love to hear from you if you want
to leave a comment under the video I
always try to respond to all of them
that I see so please leave a comment
under the video and thank you and we'll
see you on the next episode
you